bella tutti ragazzi intervenuti questo
video sono famiglie ci siamo sul terzo
ed ultimo episodio della storia di otto
degli sketch
sono contento quando a zero il nome del
gioco perché proprio difficile da dire
solo un polipo riuscirebbe porca vacca
chi me l'ha fatto fare di avere una
famiglia spiegatemi chi me l'ha fatto
fare
gesù potevo fare il polipo normale io
come tutte le persone normali
mi scarlett ma perché è cambiata la
lingua ma li mortacci vai
comunque io non ho capito ragazzi sto
gioco qual cosa mi dovrebbe portare se
non scusa al bidone moglie moglie cosa
ci stai facendo qui che problemi ma non
è mia moglie ma com'è possibile non era
una trappola dai mi ha denotato ma
perché è cambiata la lingua porca vacca
vi traduco quali altri come te ci sono
perché sono tutti i pesci che bella
risposta tornado e sei arrivato che sono
brava fare traduzioni
ma quella comunque non era mia moglie
cioè all'inizio era uguale a mia moglie
poi diventata un'anguria come dio dove
che siamo dall'acquario suo fido sulla
su una nave da aspetto anche fisica come
com'è possibile
esci fuori senza farti scoprire va bene
non badate alle tegole di legno che vi
arrivano davanti io passo tranquilli
come sono così addormentato che succede
ma devo prendere il caffè per svegliarmi
ma va a cagare ma aspetta aspetta stai
fermo ma edizione da almeno un po tutti
a quanto stealth è cascato hai fatto
cadere tu sei ubriaco non senza accordo
permesso cosa fa l'albero maestro
insegna bella questa
ma io vorrei venire a strangolarsi se
posso posso non mi avete visto non mai
visto è tutto tranquillo qua normale
tranquilli gli easy niente di strano
tutto a posto kakà come hanno fatto a
vedermi arca vacca e che ci arrivi ci
sono arrivato con il piedino ok cerca un
buon travestimento
lo trovo probabilmente dentro il
lucchetto ragazzi ma non ho la chiave
per aprirlo che ne so io dovevamo perché
ci sono delle banane per terra ma dio
mio che già è difficile sto gioco ci
mettete pure le banane
eccola la chiave qual è la chiave la
chiave quella assieme una capo che
perfetto
eccolo perfetto ok adesso nessuno mi
misco sono un essere umano come voi
vai alla sala comando mi scusi ancora
questo c'è c'è quello ma mi deve rompere
le barre come hai fatto a seguirmi sulla
nave spiega mi se la stanza del capitano
ma certo il vestito per lui ero
dimenticato il cappello aspetto 7
aspetti aspetti può fare il cosplay
decapita eccomi qua anche questo questo
posso metterlo nell'occhio ti dica mi
dica non ho capito cosa ha detto perché
ero troppo interessato a mettermi a
visivi city andiamo a comandare la nave
posso andare a dirigere voi stupidi
mozzi assolutamente rimuovi gli oggetti
dalla mappa adesso navighiamo secondo i
miei le mie direttive questo polipo come
si veste da essere umano nessuno
riconosce mai possibile e mi scusi non
volevo sto cercando aviary modalità
difficile
così devi fare il capitano a posto cosa
ci fa quella li cosa ci fa mia voglia è
stata ma mai un sogno questo perché c'è
mia moglie cioè il o viscusi mi scusi
non volevo devo devo girare
io posso comandare proprio la nave ma
come sono incastrati che ha messo la
sciarpa cosa servono le scialuppe a
salvarvi tanto dovete morire tutti
quindi non serve a niente tesoro tesoro
ti ho vista mi eseguito sulla nave borgo
antico rapida serie di nervose
spiegazioni sono un capitano borbottio
comico per schivare la domanda da
potresti fare la youtubers e proprio
simpatica oddio mio
va bene ecco credo sia questa non ne
sono sicurissimo
stavo cadendo anche giu quindi apprezza
al tentativo è comunque una ballata più
dignitosa di quelli che ballavano la
tectonic per carità di dio
brava brava distrae non distrae lo
distrae la brava moglie brava brava
io guido guido io non era proprio questa
la mia intenzione prova bene a con che
ti sei tolto il cappello ad esso dovesse
essere riconoscibile però non ti ha
riconosciuto comunque bravo continua a
tenere la tua identità segreta nessuno
scopriamo anche se un polipo
ecco ci stava effettivamente sognando
quindi niente ragazza ormai faccio parte
dell'acquario non tornano metri dalla
mia famiglia
ora cav h c'è uno sguardo ma tra tutti i
pesci e le cose che creature marine che
proprio mete vi deve inseguire un
borbottio diversamente serenità mia
figlia mi riconosce mia figlia mi
riconosce no mi chiamo made in torta
male
mai uno smile house dance che cattivi
ragazzi andrò a riprendermi la mia
famiglia perché deve andare così deve
finire così ragazzi non ha senso che io
venga trattato come un polipo perché non
lo so è sì lo sono sono anche un tubo
alle volte dipende dalla situazione
potresti togliere grazie raggiungi la
caffetteria
devo riuscire a passare di qua porca
vacca questo senta signor squalo non è
che può fare il cavolo che vuole però
stato sta facendo la voce triste non è
per niente triste anzi è anche un po
sotto effetto di ketamina secondo me
indossa il costume da scuola ma devo
fargli il costume non notare cioè non
far fai finta di niente se vedi la roba
muoversi ma sto facendo
ok perfetto perfetto ora non sono un
polipo ma sono uno squalo se sono uno
squalo va bene mi scusi scusi c'è alcun
vetro permesso l'avete rotto volo ai
cavoli vostri trade tornado ventre quale
questa è la caffetteria permesso può che
in teoria ci dovrei essere ragazzi in
teoria gesù eccoci ma perché ha legato
mio figlio centrato allegato solo lui
gli altri non sono legati borbottio che
annuncia l'arrivo eccolo eccolo
ma come sono tutti
mia figlia lo sapeva lei lo sapeva solo
lei può il programmato in arrivo corri
corri corri mio dio c'è mia figlia se
n'era accorta solo lei
porca vacca ragazza parte veramente
difficile siamo al finale mi ricordo che
questo è il finale però è penso sia
difficile amore sto benissimo e ti devo
spiegare tante cose presente quella
volta che lo facevamo e non è perché
sono molle non possono capitolo cioè è
difficile grazie dove son finito arrivo
arrivo un attimo e cammina c dugo i
tentacoli zia
eccolo ma i cori euro dai corra lenti
brava figlia a il momento della resa dei
conti vai bloccate le fontanelle con la
sedia
posso annunciare una seria ok 1 beta che
miseno nella battaglia di un boss più
strana che abbiate mai visto
ora come svogliato il mio personaggio
nel combattere tra l'altro spetta beta
ecco qua sai io ti consiglio di
toglierti la gente come non detto l'ho
battuto affronta lo chef credo di averlo
definitivamente battuto le senti zio mi
hai rotto le balle tutto sto tempo a lo
devo toccare forse io posso toccarti lo
sta facendo
mamma ma che te frega sportivo di
comprensione che bello questi giorni che
belli questi giochi che hanno un
significato che bello sentire il rumore
brutta fatto di botti cazzo riti siete
stati adottati cosa ride ma non fa
ridere è in teoria è quello però come te
lo spieghiamo
questo è successo così va da voi che se
di titoli ricorda è bellissimo io posso
muovermi nel cinema signori 8 rebs del
lei e sketch è stata ditemi se non è
stata la cosa più bella della vita
cioè io credo che questo sia il gioco
del mondo proprio del mondo allora
grafica incredibile fisica over the top
c'è anche la morale cosa aspettate a
fare della stoffa su due giocate a
doctor the fate prima quindi ragazzi
spero che vi sia piaciuto cose se vivo
il ragionamento mi piace anche per
schizzare senza quelli fischiati e non
ci vediamo seguita da ragazzi
[Musica]